hallo leute teure mal wat und willkommen
zu einer neuen folge laufen und sanften
und heute live vom deichbrand festival
2022 wir werden hier ein wunderschönes
wochenende verbringen und hoffentlich
jetzt viel essen heute mache ich mal den
markt kommt mit
[Musik]
ein klassiker von festival food ist für
mich auf jeden fall hand brot nicht nur
auf dem weihnachtsmarkt schmeckt es mega
dann auch schon mit ein paar bier intus
und wir holen uns jetzt mal ein wir sind
heute zu viert unterwegs deswegen können
wir wieder ordentlich probieren mal
gucken was sie so haben okay was haben
sie denn hier so schön ist oh ja ich
will eins ohne schwanz wegen laktose
sonst muss ich gleich ins dixi-klo dass
wir nicht schön ja hallo schön und tag
ihr verkauft die hand brot habt ihr
vegan spannend ok
ja das ist okay das ok
also es gibt schinken käse
siehst du den käse hammer
dankeschön zu den frischen käse
lecker lecker lecker jetzt kommt der
große hand protest die käse situation
ist hier schon mal super
wirklich
der perfekte snack wenn man schon so ein
bisschen was getrunken hat schnell was
im wagen braucht was dagegen arbeitet
wissen wir ein bisschen würziger könnte
es seien sieben von zehn auf jeden fall
während wir gerade unser hand brot
genossen haben hat uns schon ein anderer
stand hin gewunken um eine
probierportionen zu bekommen der
käsespätzle stand hier bekommt man
anscheinend käsespätzle war ja mit
schnittlauch und andres zwiebeln perfekt
dankeschön das ist hier nicht billiger
gouda das ist hier nicht irgendwie das
riecht drehe ich mich nach käse effekte
probierportionen für mich schaut euch
das an schnittlauch zwiebeln
[Musik]
sehr lecker sehr lecker sehen von 10 o
mein gott
auf zum nächsten stand
das problem ist ja wir haben zwei
leckere sachen gegessen aber wir haben
ja hier noch eine veganerin unter uns ja
das bin ich und deswegen müssen wir so
das ist niemandem managerin und beste
freundin und jetzt wissen wir was
veganes essen also gehen wir zum base
stand hallo ich komme jetzt mal die
influenza- besucher wir brauchen das
vegan ist wir nehmen sie die surprise
die laufen anscheinend mega gut wir
müssen aber die veganerin fragen
möchtest du gysi frites essen unbedingt
sehr gern sie frei sind vegan ich glaube
da kann man nicht viel falsch machen das
glaube ich auch nicht dass sie dir nach
der pause nach der werbung ihr bruder
[Musik]
also das gute ist jetzt schon mal wir
haben ja ein pluspunkt es ist wege hand
vor mir erstmal falafel
[Musik]
verabredet crunchy verlaufen schon mal
dass zehn von zehn
würde ich auch sagen würde ich auch
sagen jetzt probieren wir haben den
preis
das ist käse das ist curry und die
andere ist curry mango das ist ein
flavour explosion im mund jetzt einmal
für euch mund aufmachen haben sie würden
würden wir die promis bewerten also
insgesamt
neun von zehn
[Musik]
das war jetzt alles schon ziemlich
lecker aber irgendwie fehlt mir noch was
die da hinten hängt ein luftballon also
da kannst du nur lecker sein
ja ich habe euch schon von weitem
gesehen da hängt ja was draußen was ist
denn hier programm na ja wunderbar das
habt ihr aber auch hier hier im
ausland sind das nenne ich würde sagen
ich möchte eine aus davids und
baumkuchen eben immer so eine aussah und
ihr team das noch so ein schokolade rein
das ist eine schöne aus hast du schon
mal so eine schöne aussage sehen wir
probieren jetzt einmal die aussah mit
schokolade
ein leckerer aus der ganz toller teig
schmeckt auch gar nicht so nach
backpulver da sondern einfach so ein
schöner mürbeteig oder so wie man das
nennt ja und dann weiße schokolade und
vollmilchschokolade drauf da kann man ja
nicht viel falsch machen sieben von zehn
ich habe jetzt ja schon fast ein dessert
gegessen aber es geht noch mehr rein bin
ich ehrlich mit euch und wir sind an
einem stand vorbei gelaufen wo es käse
dünner gibt
die kann sogar hier wir probieren jetzt
den käse bühne aus ist sehr gut
ja okay gut dann kann es ja nur gut sein
er ist also
die verätzungen oder das so kann man
sich die vorräte
timo kannst du sie bitte mal anschauen
das ist wirklich wie ein döner spieß nun
mit käse die schlagen ist aber sehr
lange müssen sehr lange warten
bestellen sollen also werden wir warten
können uns ein bisschen unterhalten das
ist heute hier der erste tag es ist
donnerstag wir sind vorhin angereist mit
allem möglichen also mit campingstühlen
mit pavillon mülltüten getränke ja mehr
mülltüten toilettenpapier und wir sind
bei unserem zelt angekommen sind in
ohnmacht gefallen also dieses zelt ist
wirklich mehr kann man sich vom leben
einfach nicht wünschen da und was
erwarte ich jetzt für die nächsten tage
ich hoffe auf jeden fall die super zu
sehen zwei slices firminho in mein leben
und cello
ok ihm hinhalten ihm hinhalten
okay ich mache hat gerade gesagt ich
vergesse immer das mikro zu der person
zu halten mit der ich rede ich nicht mag
das heute hier quasi zum ersten mal mit
mikro mache muss ich noch üben oder
definitiv jetzt mit der 100er dieser
käse dönerstand korrekt wir haben den
käse döner gegründet im jahr 2009 unser
erstes festival deichbrand und seitdem
tun wir durch ganz
europa damit und sind bekannte käsebrot
die krise dünner großen was ist ihr
geheimrezept käse
also wir entscheiden uns heute für einen
zuzug diese dünner mit geschmolzenem
käse mittel scharfe peperoni knobi
rinder wurst gemüse kräuter salat sesam
panini diese kostet der 59 also eine
sache kann man sagen sich auf dem
festival durchzufüttern ist nicht
günstig einen wunderschönen guten tag
womit kann ich euer herz erfreuen wir
hätten gerne ein stück käse aber gerne
doch welche soße soll dann raufen
honig senf und barbecue wir werden
gleich barbecue nehmen oder das passt
ganz cool
ja also es wundert mich nicht wenn man
sich das hier so anschaut wundert es
mich nicht warum dieser stand so beliebt
ist und warum die schlangen vor diesem
stand so lange sind morgen wenn der
erste haupttag ist dann wird es
wahrscheinlich noch voller sein also
haben wir glück und ich probiere es
einmal kannst du die stange halten und
ich das kabel
machte ganz klasse eine beförderung
[Musik]
man bekommt was sie einem versprechen
jetzt einfach alles das ist der perfekte
nachdem ihr brokkoli konsumiert habe
jetzt fangen gemüse drauf nachos käse
röstzwiebeln barbecue sauce zwiebeln
alles und ich glaube dass jemand ein
bisschen heimweh das entwickelt hat 19
[Musik]
das mikro ist hier gerade so ein
bisschen wie sowieso eine fliegenfalle
eine sehr klebrige fliegenfalle bin ich
und die leute werden um so betrunkener
sie werden umso mehr der pegel steigt
haben sie mehr auf mich zu geflogen und
bleiben auch kleben
und damit wir diesen pegel jetzt auch
erreichen testen wir
so der frauen nachrichten die so cool
weiter moderiert muss obwohl die
dahinter also damit wir diesen pegel
hier mal auch erreichen langsam haben
wir sehen die kopierbare angestanden
hier gibt es ein special deichbrand
trinkt also ich hab gehört sie leiten ja
hier das deichbrand ja genau das mal war
der management
gehört ihm ja quasi sind ja frau
deichbrand ja so ungefähr man habe
gehört sie haben hier in ihrem cockpit
stand einen cocktail der heißt da ich
brand cocktail ja genau der extra für
sie gemacht weil sie roben lieben und
schimmel sagt noch besser finden und was
da noch so drin rechte glaube ich habe
die erste zeile gelesen ehrlich gesagt
rover
programm
der am donnerstag
[Musik]
von zapatero
nadine und beim jazz nehmen liter also
wenn wir liter nehmen dann heißt es
tschüss bis morgen wir nehmen den wir
nehmen 04 das ist das todesstoß okay
jetzt sage ich das mit hallo puppe ja
ich traue mich
hast du dem deichbrand cocktail
[Musik]
sag mal was würdest du auf dem festival
empfehlen was man am allerliebsten essen
sollte also essen das problem ist wir
haben diese nudeln mit oder juli also
wir haben nur so wo man ihnen auf jeden
fall
genau ab juli stehen und wie macht ihr
das wasser war das kkh
interview zum ende jetzt probieren wir
den deichbrand cocktail
[Musik]
meine seele grad mein körper verlassen
das ist das stärkste was ich jemals in
meinem leben getrunken habe
[Musik]
gut dass wir kein liter bestellt haben
dieses ding hat uns aus dem leben raus
viel zu stark so schrecklich ist
wirklich
[Musik]
aber er tut was er soll wieder gerne
haben
so und jetzt wo sich bei uns alles dreht
weil wir getrunken gegessen haben
austern gegessen haben gehen wir jetzt
auch das riesenrad und drehen uns noch
mal im kreis visco interview niemand
aber max was sagen hallo also wir sind
jetzt hoffen riesen wenn wir jetzt
einmal raus schaffen retten uns quasi
geradeaus riesenrad super leute hier
also auch wenn ich meine witze machen
deichbrand besucher sind wirklich die
nettesten die man so kennt wirklich sehr
tolle menschen jetzt gehen wir mal eine
runde auf dem riesenrad fahren unser
rummel video haben wir auch schon im
riesenrad
verbracht ich finde das sollte einfach
ein ding sein ja kein bisschen mehr dass
du bist ja irgendwie teil des videos
diesmal hofmann sieht das ganze camp
alles was die sonne berührt gehört dir
aber die haben alle mal jung wir dürfen
unser nicht aufbauen das war's für diese
folge laufen und laufen hier aus dem
höchsten punkt vom deichbrand es war
wirklich sehr sehr lecker alles ne also
auch mit den drei bier intus die wir
hatten waren wirklich ein absoluter
schmaus das war genau richtig was wir
gebraucht haben über die preise brauche
ich nicht sagen es ist keine ahnung
inflation und festival und ich also
darüber kann ich nicht sagen
geschmacklich was wirklich sehr lecker
coole neue sachen käse döner kann ich
absolut nicht die aussah war köstlich
wenn es etwas gibt was ich nicht
probiert habe und wo ihr sagt wann es
herr bis zu denn du musst noch sowas auf
dem festival letzten schreibe es in die
kommentare und abonniert den kanal wenn
ihr da unten
bis dann
überflüssig